since Trump entered his run for the
presidency in 2016
Democrats and their media sycophants
have been on an absolute mission to not
just defeat him but to destroy him and
all those around him as well they're all
so blinded by their hatred of all things
Trump so much so that they've hitched
their political wagons to a cast of
radical unsavory characters that looks
like a reunion of the Suicide Squad
enter Michael avenatti
a two-bit tax sheet a celebrity attorney
reborn as crusading lawyer to porn star
Trump accusers stormy Daniels the
president trusted mr. Cohen as his fixer
for years he trusted him with his
innermost secrets and I think that the
chickens are about to come home to roost
now they're coming home to roost all
right as a battering ram against Donald
Trump and later his Supreme Court
nominee Brett Kavanaugh avenatti was
elevated by the left the media couldn't
get enough avenatti he went from
hawkster hard-charging plaintiff's
lawyer to a nationwide brand his face
was suddenly plastered all over TV and
print well this profile from Vanity Fair
is my personal favorite there he is the
racecar driving lawyer with the shaved
head and well-defined cheekbones who
launched a thousand heart eye emojis oh
my I don't think I can continue now the
piece goes on to address some pretty
salacious rumors about his tan
I don't fake bake he said he does
moisturize twice a day but shuns
complicated skincare products such as
eye creams and 40-minute masks at one
point last spring he was getting 100 to
125 interview requests a day he was soon
a featured guest at glittery events as
well like MTV's Video Music Awards well
maybe they confused him I don't know
with that rapper Pitbull I see the
similarity their political and
entertainment the political and
entertainment media these worked
overtime to showcase all things avenatti
thank you very much which right is right
you saw this coming you were putting a
lot of chips on what was going to happen
with Michael Cohen and what it would
mean for your case but today your stacks
look a little higher a little little
higher all right Michael avenatti thank
you very much appreciate look avenatti
has been getting fed information that is
wound up being more true than not what
he's doing on TV that's his business and
the people who put him on we're going to
bring in a key player from all of this
Michael avenatti because he sees it
differently
curiously neither Cuomo nor Don Lemon
though covered a vanadis arrest last
night by the LAPD on domestic abuse
charges huh what are Y though last night
Anderson Cooper did cover a vanadis post
prison press conference and I appreciate
it thank you
that's Michael avenatti who's just I
guess MJ been been released from custody
we're of course going to continue to
follow the story tonight there's even
more breaking news this time in the
Russian investigation potentially big
development as we wait for new moves
from special counsel molar that isn't it
wait wait wait wait I missed that wait
was it that was like a drive-by mention
okay can we move on to the next topic
now please go go go well from Weinstein
to Sharpton the Farrakhan and now to
avenatti the Democrats have a pattern
don't they of aligning themselves with
seedy figures even if it means betraying
the Democrats espouse values to that
would have actually advance their cause
the Democrats are more than happy to
sell out basic principles of decency and
fairness in their efforts to take down
Trump and frankly anyone connected to
him at least avenatti was forthright in
his intentions though I believe that our
party the Democratic Party must be a
party that fights fire with fire
so I say when they go low we hit harder
[Applause]
but the Dems should have seen the
avenatti flame out coming a mile away a
guy who tried to cheat his law partner
at a millions and fees a guy who was
evicted from his own offices who was
willing to cast his lot with a sad
figure like Daniels a guy who stooped
even lower to peddle Julie sweat nicks
falls and frankly defamatory claims
against Kavanagh avenatti was an arrest
waiting to happen in fact last month
Senator Senate Judiciary Committee Chair
chuck Grassley made a criminal referral
to both avenatti and sweat Nick for
making false statements to Congress and
this was some guy you know that the
left's and can seriously considered as a
presidential contender for 2024 months
Clinton alum Adam Parker mentaiko has
been shuttling the lawyer avenatti from
Democratic Party events and Democratic
Party event all over the country in
order to film
your eyes oven addy with the whole
process of running for the Presidency
and the Vermont Democratic Party
actually canceled a vanadis appearance
this weekend following his arrest well
in a twist of fate the man who urged us
to believe the women making wild
decades-old allegations against
Cavanaugh now has a change of
perspective
I have never struck a woman I never will
strike a woman I have been an advocate
for women's rights my entire career and
I'm going to continue to be an advocate
I am NOT going to be intimidated from
stopping what I am doing I have a
question can you advocate for women's
rights behind bars I guess they do have
that those desks set up in prison
how will Democrats and liberal women who
embrace this would be Trump Slayer react
now to this he's innocent until proven
guilty and I said that last night
but will CNN give even a fraction of the
airtime to his accuser as they did to
his clients don't hold your breath and
that's the angle